[Applause]
got to go so when when we talked about
this you know the wew work team's like
do you want to come and give a keynote
and I was like not really right
especially for how fast this thing sold
out since I tweeted it I you know I'm
assuming a lot of people have a lot of
context and like how many [__] times
can you hear that I made $4,000 on
baseball cards
so you know I thought it'd be far more
interesting to answer your exact
questions as deep or is you know now so
I wanted to open up so let's go there's
one over there let's go
there Mike wait for the Mike cuz I want
to make sure we get
it and what's your name it's I know that
and thank you so much for the sparkling
wine you're welcome I will drink that
whole bottle I'm join um I wanted to
know how many views you got the first
time you did wi Library like the first
episode of wine lbr TV yeah uh I think
it was 27
um and I was [__] pumped I was like
27 people watch this holy [__] this is
awesome I mean listen I'm telling you
there is a complete
ridiculous awful thought process in our
startup environment right now like when
you have 98 followers on Twitter 98
people 98 human beings want to hear your
dumbest [__] random thoughts do you
know how thankful you should be and so I
mean it like it's funny I haven't
thought about this thank you for asking
this question I was pumped because first
of all one thing you going to know like
do you know why I want to buy the New
York Jets it's a long journey right I
love the journey I don't like [__] I
don't want to buy stuff I don't want a
car all my friends are like I want a
Tesla [__] Tesla you know I want you
know like like I don't want those things
I I like the journey so 27 meant
tomorrow I better get 49 right like I'm
the kind of guy who hates going
backwards you know what I fear going the
other way like I don't like winning a
lot I don't like where I'm at right now
in some weird way I like when like I
loved coming into the agency World cuz
nobody knew who the hell I was right
they're like oh that's like you know
like I love that I'm like good good
sleep sleep on me [__] you know like
I like that that's who I am I don't like
this like oh you're good and like you're
great like I hate that you know like I I
mean let me start over I love it I love
I I love it I love the admiration I love
the engagement I love that it gives me
an opportunity to engage with people and
see people that I like I love it I do
love that but boy do I really love the
climb I love the climb and so none
nobody give a [__] about me nothing a
year and a half forget about that let's
talk about real [__] a year and a half
and not a lot was going on it was slow
it would listen things were tougher to
get viral at some level social wasn't in
place Facebook was kids and school edu
only Twitter wasn't here yet right like
you know yes I could get like a Blog
mention on you know but I didn't but I
wasn't good enough like I didn't like I
didn't get life hacker right that first
time when I went outside and tasted wine
in the snow and like I was like if this
doesn't get me on dig I'm going to kill
somebody and it did thank
God but you know it was like things like
that and it was just being strategic
right like you know obviously Kevin Rose
and Alex alre were doing a bunch of
stuff for all the techies in here on
dignation it was trying figure out how
to like get into that Circle of video
bloggers and so um it took time and by
the way it was happening while my
business was starting to go stale for
the first time ever because I wasn't
paying attention to.com anymore in the
store I was trying to build my brand so
it wasn't happening when I was 22 and
had nothing to really worry about other
than maybe you're sharing apartment and
with your friends that you maybe can't
go out as many nights as you can mine
was I'm supp going to lose money and so
like it took like a stomach to like be
like this is
right
[Music]
yeah what does your intuition tell you
about line in the future for what it
will do for
Branding what was that what does your I
got I got I'm extremely bullish on Vine
um in a big way so first of all I think
that time is our biggest asset um and
what Vine the app does gives you a
promise that this is only 6 seconds of
your time it's a much bigger deal than
most people are making it out to me
you've got to promise that you're not
going to be spending that much time you
know when you hit that button you know
where you're at so one I love that two I
believe in human creativity much more
than most people anybody in your circles
are like what can you do in six seconds
or how do you tell a story in 6 seconds
they're fools they don't they're not
paying attention we had this
conversation around what you can say in
140 characters that ship is sailed we
know that works so I know you can tell
stories in six seconds I'm watching them
every day I've been spending an enormous
amount of time on Vine I'm up to some
[__] on Vine um I'm very bullish on it I
think Vine does to YouTube what Twitter
did to Facebook which takes a core
feature makes it the whole thing that it
actually does and brings a lot of value
when you start understanding how many
people watch YouTube for a couple of
seconds and then move on if they don't
like it you start getting into a very
fascinating place the thing I find most
interesting is divine celebrities that
have popped up that have never been
famous anywhere else not a YouTube Star
you know there's people have three four
500,000 followers on buy right now I
have 7,000 right so just CU you killed
it somewhere else doesn't mean you're
going to kill it here and I love that I
love the capitalism of a new creative
genre that you have to be as good as you
can on that platform to succeed I think
from branding you're going to see a ton
of great branded content and in 6
seconds it's not going to piss you off
and so that gets into like that could be
interesting Brands might actually be
able to get away with doing some stuff
that you may actually actually want to
watch I also think is a dirty little
secret that Vine's going to change the
pre-roll industry I think that once
everybody understands you can tell a
story in six seconds that you'll never
see a 30 second and 15sec pre-roll again
we'll start seeing 6 seconds which makes
everybody happy here and you know so I
think it's a very important platform I
think it's grossly underestimated by a
lot of thought leaders I think a lot of
8 to 18yar old kids know what's up I
think this is going to be the summer
Vine for the normal kids and I think
that um come the fall people to be
paying attention in a very big
[Music]
way hey what's your name I'm John I've
read all your books I'm a huge fan
thanks bro I recently just started a
vlog and I'm actually interviewing you
in August so I'm really excited for that
and right I'm I'm doing an interview
Series this year where I'm doing an
interview a day 365 different interviews
One A Day for blogs and I only tweeted
it out and only wanted my fans or
friends or people that paid attention to
me I didn't want mainstream stuff so I
really appreciate that I didn't think I
was going to get P so super excited
about that thanks man looking forward to
I will bring it be ready I'm going to be
ready I'm excit um one of my questions
is like I said I just start a blog and
I've read all your books and I'm all
about giving back but I also work
fulltime yeah I was wonder if you had
any advice like how to scale to give my
best to my job that's where I'm making
my money right now and eventually yes I
want to do my Blog full time and teach
people how to network but how can I give
the best to
both by putting in the time I it's the
only asset you got right right like
that's your asset like you know and you
know this if you read the books I'm
obsessed with this notion of 7:00 p.m.
to 2:00 in the morning like you know you
know listen I complain every day like
[__] man I need to lose some weight and
like this that the other I yell at like
my new assistant Mike I'm like you got
to skip but the truth is I'm not putting
in the work at time like when I tell
everybody that they can sleep one hour
less if they want to build a business I
can sleep one hour less to hit the gym
right so you know it's what you put in
man like you need you know what I like
about this though is work takes up a lot
of time and energy but when you're
actually doing something you love it's a
little bit easier to put in that 10 p.m.
11: p.m I mean listen
a bunch of us I see a couple of guys
here at V Meer were in the office the
other day 2 o'clock in the morning the
1:30 in the morning it's the latest I've
been there why because from 9:00 to 1:30
in the morning we were working on my
brand for the first time in a long time
cu the book is coming and guess what I
love my brand you know I love me and
that was it was easy I wasn't tired I
didn't want to go to sleep and so um you
know the thing that I would tell you to
do that gives you the best prayer for
this to work is make sure you're really
in tune and self-aware that this blog is
around the thing that you like the most
you know don't make it about
interviewing internet peeps like unless
that's the thing you want it unless you
grew up one day I want to be Charlie
Rose unless that's right but you know if
one day you wanted to like ride
dinosaurs make it about [__]
dinosaurs cool and then just a quick
thing like the first question you were
saying that only like 27 people watched
your um first one library video um how
long how did you stay positive when you
first started like for me like I have
like 100 followers yes I'm grateful but
like I read a lot of other things like
oh like you should be going a lot faster
and stuff like that but like I'm kind of
about like the quality of them but I was
just wondering if you had anything to
say about I'm
patient you know like stuff doesn't
happen as like you know the problem is
Kevin system [__] annihilates it
sells Instagram in two years for Billy
and everybody's like [__] that's what we
need to like what the [__] is the matter
with people like right for every one
instagram there is 9 billion
[__] got it got it but yet we just all
want to be that and think that's going
to happen we're never living in a better
time where you have an opportunity to
build a business because the business
opportunities now are often predicated
more than ever on talent and time and
effort you put into it because the
internet this amazing invention that
came along and all these amazing
entrepreneurs that are building things
on top of it are creating efficiency
that don't cost us money and they give
us the time and effort and our skill to
story tell and create you know but we
just need to be patient you know like
but nothing you asked me I'm grateful I
mean think about how you asked me that
question I'm grateful for those 100 but
[__] but take that out of your equation
and just do your [__] thanks so much I
appreciate you you got
to
yeah up what's up uh Jeff Jeff Amos oh
yes Jeff what's up man it's good to see
you you too um so I had a quick question
there's the one thing I could never
figure out about like product
development is um I like to teach people
how to learn things the thing I'm trying
to teach people right now is something
that everyone's so [__] pumped to
learn but like no one actually [__]
goes to actually learn or do it and it's
DJing right everyone wants to become a
DJ and I actually saw the Tweet you said
about DJing is probably not what people
should be doing like not being creators
by creators but I mean it's aw I say
that I thought I said there was a value
of money against that right that if
you're the core creator of it there's a
different value prop that you know DJs
are killing it in let's call it music
getting paid a lot but the royalties of
the Creator the songs are an interesting
money Trail to follow it's happening in
internet as well right so I believe in
it DJ I mean yeah dedm I mean DJ is at
its height right so plenty of cash um so
I didn't say that's not the right thing
to do it's a different value CR it's all
go ahead cool so like in terms of like
like even when you're like trying to
pitch an idea to you a company they want
to do something how do you get people
actually invest in the idea and sell
them on something they already want to
do but they're just not taking that
first step especially if like learning
products I've seen other friends
companies have so much trouble with that
but I to get people to bite I mean you
know to answer your question directly
because I'm the greatest salesman of all
time right and I'm joking but what I
mean is I'm a good salesman like I but
here's why I always start with the
finish line for the other person and let
me say that again cuz it's really
important the reason I'm a good salesman
is cu I always think about the finish
line for the other person not what's in
it for me that's the best way to be a
good salesperson but nobody wants to do
that that's why it's hard to be a good
salesperson um so I would tell you that
if you're not getting traction for what
you're doing you need to ask a hell of a
lot more questions I would go backwards
to everybody that you ever tried to sell
it to and ask them why they didn't buy
it and create a safe environment where
they're not going to hurt your feelings
because you need to figure out why thank
[Music]
you hi hi Pamela hey Pamela I was just
wondering if you heard of data Miner and
what you think of it I have heard of
data minor so he's out today
got yeah so I'm an investor in data
minor um so part of it uh
that was so fun to sit
on um so I know the I mean I had signed
papers last week knowing this news was
coming so is the question what do I
think of them or
yeah I mean you know money where your
mouth is right I believe in those guys
quite a bit they're extremely smart I
like investing in things I'm not you
know I respect data in a way that you
could never imagine um but I I prefer EQ
over IQ so it's fun for me to invest in
data driven companies because I like
staying close to those things it was
that was a very obvious one for me um I
thought they were very smart I'm very
deep into Twitter as many people here
know they were one of the first people
that I think really thought about
Twitter the way I did but from the Yang
I thought about it from the heart they
thought about it from the brain EQ IQ um
so they felt like my brothers just you
know looking at it from a different lens
I'm very bullish on that company I'd be
dumbfounded if that is not a billion
dollar exit company that's how ahead
they are and that's how important what
they do
is and I'm pumped you ask me that
because now we have the video of he's
saying that so when they do go for 1.3
billion I'll chop this little piece and
put out of micro content and see told
you
[__] thank thank
you man do I love I Told You So by the
way go read all the comments and crushit
Amazon reviews back in 2008 about my
thoughts on Tumblr and how I was
completely out of my mind and didn't
know what I'm talking about if you don't
think I went back the other night and
emailed all those
people I just want you to know who
you're dealing with went back and
emailed them and said yo now
what so I love the I Told You So I live
where I told you so I think it's why I
put so much out
there hey G Mich um hey man what's your
name Michael Michael apologies if you
already talked about this I can't late
you worries you mentioned something
recently about doubling down on content
yes and apparently having I guess
someone following you yes full time and
I was going to see coming I if you could
elaborate on that or I know someone
picked that up kind of Rand with it and
I guess you kind of came back and that's
not yeah it's kind of a good example of
like you know I'm a master communicator
and all this stuff but I think I dropped
the ball in that article you know I
don't I think dory's a really good
reporter this whole notion that I'm
going to have you know somebody
following me 24/7 like reality show and
where like beta be and other people took
it it's just it's not the truth right
Steve's back there he's here right very
handsome man you should meet him but you
know you know Steve sent me you know
something last night he's like what do
you think about this this is a
conversation I'm like no you know like
he we you know we talk about stuff but
it's more about I'm very
unorganized I have so many ideas that
fly in and out of my head and I'm not
good at taking it even taking my phone
out and writing it down is not something
I'm capable of it's probably why I
failed all my classes right I know a lot
of people that are running successful
companies that are successful people
that are artists and taste makers and
create amazing content better than me
right they're also very similar so I
think as content becomes more and more
important I do see this world where you
know somebody calls you at the end of
the day or you know why Steve's here
somebody's G to ask a question there's
been some good ones here some different
ones than I'm talking about and he's
taking note I'm taking note and it's
just a a backup service to you know kind
of infrastructure a human infrastructure
to be like hey that was such a great
question by him should we do something I
need that push a little bit it's I I
when I do work out only with a trainer
I'm just not self-motivated in a lot of
places I believe in content so much I
believe in it so much I feel like I'm
letting a lot of good stuff get away and
out of my brain and by having that
discipline with another person it's
helping me remember it create more he
also has a huge wine background I'm
missing wine so yeah I mean I do think
that people are going to be doubling and
tripling down on content and I do think
it's going to be a trend and I think I
think creating content is the cost of
relevance in our society right now I
really do I really think content is
amazingly amazingly important I think
that's Baseline I think if you're not
creative content you're in trouble and
then I think what happens next context
or how talented you are I have no
concern about the quality quantity
debate because I know my filter I'm not
going to put out crap right and more
importantly the market decides what's
crap and not plenty of people in this
room think the Kardashians are crap but
enough consumers say they're not and
good for them you know what I mean
plenty of people drink Yellow Tail I
think it's [__] good for Yellow Tail
right so I mean I think that I think
that I love how everybody all of a
sudden thinks they're holier than now to
decide what is quality in our society
you know what quality is what people
[__] buy period consumer always is
Right consumers always always right
period thank
[Applause]
you hey Gary Sam sheer hey hey man how
are you good good to see you good to see
you um you good uh What super well um
what's the best piece of advice you've
ever been
given there's two that stick out only
two and I have I'm really bad at being
mentored I think I have a lot of flaws
that's one of them I like to like I'm in
myself I'm in my own cocoon you know I'm
undereducated I think but I think all
that stuff actually helps me because a
lot of my stuff comes from like a naive
that becomes very authentic and maybe a
different way to look at it so it's
become a weird Advantage um in a world
where information has become a commodity
um there's two the best one is the one
my dad gave me when I first started when
I came to my dad when I was 14 I was a
full of crap salesman I would have told
you anything about any baseball card or
wine just to make sure you bought it and
my dad really taught me word is bond he
told me you make a commitment you stick
to it it really stuck to me and it came
at the right time I was probably only
one or two years away from from never
being able to fix it and I'm very very
grateful for that me being dragged into
my dad's liquor store that one thing
saved me it's why a lot of people I'm
sure people in here when they first
consumed me might have thought I was
like an infomercial huster salesman I'm
I'm I'm over the top right and like very
easy to dismiss because of my energy and
Insanity right and I think that comes
with being a [__] salesman and I had
that in me and I think my dad really
writed that course and that's huge the
other one came from an old old salesman
my dad had a liquor salesman we had so I
was buying from M1 Point who was like 83
years old right old dude great guy and
one day we're just sitting there I'm
buying and I was talking about hiring or
something of that nature and he looked
at me and said Gary let me give you a
piece of advice and I'm like you know I
hate advice so I was like yeah go old
three time right I was
16 and he said uh he said 17 and he said
uh I just want you to know one thing he
had this great voice I go what's that he
said
you don't know what you have until you
sleep with
it and it was interesting right I was
like oh well Dirty Man
ha but as my life has gone on with the
way that I hire with the way that I
invest with the way that I make
friendships you don't know what you have
until you sleep with it you know I
reverse I'm a coach that makes
adjustments at halftime doesn't
overstress the game plan the week before
and that's what that saying is about
which is you can plan everything you
want you can have everything lined up in
a row but then stuff happens then
there's something you didn't see in that
person that existed and it's what you do
next that matters much more than what
you did to get to that moment I'm proud
that I'm really good at adversity
halftime adjustments I feel like I'm if
I was a coach I'd be a coach known for
being down 21 nothing and winning 2721
because I'd probably prep a little less
on the upfront and catch our team off
guard but I know exactly what to do once
I tasted it thanks
yeah we have time for one more question
is that it but then Jesse is going to
talk to you again so it's okay why more
questions more questions lots more
questions hold on like 10
more sorry I'm just checking I think the
baby's is the baby
here holy [__] my sister had a
baby
[Applause]
hold on boy girl
girl
amazing so amazing all
right it's going be tough to be
calibrate hey how are you doing well I
had a quick question for you in regards
to the Q&A a day that you've been doing
yes just wanted to hear about how that's
going and what you've learned from it so
far great so two things one Manisha you
shouldn't have taken the mic away from
all these lovely people because you're
in the office with me every [__] day
and you could ask me that tomorrow
that's number one um number two um how's
it going it's going extremely well I
have gotten to a place in my career
where I can get with right if I want to
go on CNN or CNBC or do a Fast Company
article I'm in a crazy place so thankful
I can get nothing but press they love me
I'm a quotable [__] right all
that stuff right so they're in I can get
it with distribution High you know
awareness what I really what I really
wanted to focus on with this is depth I
really am thankful for my community I
really am I don't say 100 but you know I
I'm thankful and so I wanted 365 of them
who and it was interesting for me when
Joe brought that up I knew that a 100
people would start a blog
just to interview me literally start
their blog to get me to be on their
interview because they wanted to spend
the time and plenty have I'm getting
little to no awareness from all this
time 15 minutes every day when I have a
billion things going on for a Blog
that's going to be read or watched by
six 9 11 people but that's not why I'm
doing it I'm doing it because I wanted
to thank people I wanted them to
leverage my name to build their blog I
wanted to spend 15 minutes with them
because they've been watching and
consuming and retweeting and sharing and
reblogging my stuff for 3 four years and
I knew this was a way that I could thank
them that meant something that and
that's why I did it and so you know why
it's going great cuz it was great from
the second I decided to do it that ship
sailed I was good because it wasn't for
[Music]
me question this my what's your name
Eddie Eddie pleasure be a little broad
but where do you think creative
Innovation is headed
to I think where is cre I mean it is a
little broad um but let me take it where
I can take it right I think
that let let me ask you a
question Define
cool something
that I can relate to that I you know I
really should have yeah and so like if
we asked everybody and I'm sure
everybody's doing it through their mind
right it's a tough thing to explain but
I actually think creative has to be cool
and I think where cool comes in for me
is relevance relevance is a very core
piece of that relevance really matters
so here's what I think relevance plus
value equals where I think that world's
that's all I think about how do I bring
value I could have came up here did my
thing for 45 minutes dropped the mic
gave you the same thing that I normally
do and a lot of you would have been
pumped because you would have said oh I
finally got to see it in person and it
would have felt different I've been
shocked I'm so thankful that people have
seen my keynote nine times and still
love it you know it's like that comedian
you like listen I'll go see Chris Rock
38 times in a row I get it but you know
what brings more value what we're doing
right now like you know I love Jess but
I didn't want him to like I want you to
get this this is value I think access is
going to be a very valuable thing going
forward above content but I think
relevance really matters swag you know
context knowing what's happening like
you know that thing is so valuable right
and I think Brands and businesses and
entrepreneurs and everybody not that
they have to be cool but they have to be
cool the definition of cool for the demo
they're trying to sell you just have to
know it's a o Library TV back to the
people that are here for that it really
worked because I was reviewing wine but
I was throwing in pop culture references
that were happening in the world at that
moment that made it for the younger
demos seem a little cooler here's a wine
guy that talks about X like I was talk
about fart you know Bass from Gossip
Girl at its height that mattered to a
lot of people especially me and so you
know so I I think that's where it's
going I think that the cost of being a
successful creative has been pushed very
heavy into relevance and value and less
on just pushing something down someone's
throat
thank
you I'm actually really happy to hear
you say that you believe in young people
pretty amped about that um but as a
fellow I don't believe in higher
education uh neither do I that's why I'm
here to change it actually um but as a
fellow climber what could we be doing
better to improve those uh college
students that are graduating coming into
your doors to work
there it's such a this is such a topic I
mean I I uh I get to go around the
country and speak at colleges that I
never could have ever even thought like
that if I would have applied they would
have punched me in the mouth right um
and and I and I go there court and I
actually listen to the curriculum and
now I'm talking about business schools
which is obviously clearly different
than a lot of other professions I just
can give you an answer to my context and
I sit there and I sit through uh the
curriculum to create cont text and I
like literally sit there and say my God
these poor people are paying $200,000 in
debt to get this information that has
absolutely positively no value right
because and it's not their fault by the
way it's not their fault there's a ton
of entrepreneurs and full-time business
people that are trying to keep up with
the world guys the world got faster like
that's not an aberration the world is
much faster things are evolving so much
quicker because because of the
infrastructure of this thing called the
internet and so where I think the
biggest thing you could do to help them
is to talk to them like whatever it
takes the story tell to them about what
actually matters is really really
important you know I made a video
recently A lot of people took in a weird
way about me saying a lot of number two
threes and fours or starting businesses
every single I league student right now
thinks that they're going to put on a
hoodie and sell a billion dollar company
and most of them and this is me
stereotyping many of them have never
been punched in the mouth and when
you're an entrepreneur you get punched
in the mouth every day and so I've
watched a lot of startups from kids from
Brown and Yale and Stanford fold quickly
over before they started because
adversity and all these other things so
you know internships are fine and you
tell them to go Network and all left you
know I don't know I I think the problem
is by the time you get them [__] is
sailed you know I think we need to go
back to a world like here's what I'm
scared about Misha's four and Lizzie
knows I'll let her do anything she wants
and how we raise our daughter except one
thing Misha will never be in a league
where people don't win and lose Misha
will never be in a league where somebody
that comes in sixth place gets a trophy
period right and so I think there's a
lot of things going on right now that
are intriguing and I don't want to be
like the old school guy cuz I'm plenty
new school you shouldn't go to a school
where ninth where 9ye old can smoke weed
I'm in but winning and losing that stuff
matters that's stuff matters for one
simple reason cuz it matters cuz that's
what really happens later and so not
preparing peeps mentally for what's
going to happen I struggle with and you
know higher ed I mean I don't know like
you know my biggest problem is you can
declare bankruptcy by doing everything
wrong and getting a clean sleep except
your student loan right like the game is
whack period end of story and most of
all has no equal equation to success of
being an entrepreneur than if you would
have just dropped out of school at 14
and so we need to have healthy debates
there's a lot going on with this but
anything you could do to make them
understand what's real versus what's not
I'll give you another one that I
actually think really does work getting
them to go do an internship or a
mentorship with the person and starting
with number one and then if it's number
eight fine but with the person they most
want to be and like I mean I don't
understand how people don't realize the
value it is to work I think one day I'm
GNA get paid to have an intern by then I
promise you right now [__] Harvard
200,000 give me 50,000 I'll make you a
fuckload more
money so I think we're living in a
really interesting world where people
are confused about how it the business
World works and I think at least from
that context it's going to be very
interesting
hey Gary Greg um I have a question so as
a startup
entrepreneur uh and if you want to build
Partnerships with larger Brands how do
you hle your way up to big guys and play
in the big leagues and prove to them
that even though you're small fish they
should pay attention to you and do
business with you what are some of the I
would I would say the number one tip
there's a couple ways to do it number
one one of the great things to do is to
offer what you do for free to the
biggest people because if they take you
up on it now you've got the logo and the
learnings to do it number one if you can
do that number two Relentless
pressure you know I'm telling you right
now if you want to get to me and I'm
glad my assistant's not here if you want
to get to me you can here's what it
takes email me 47,000 times until I
Buckle I mean it and sometimes I buckle
on the first email
and people tweet Gary's the best first
email and then somebody sees it like
what the [__] I emailed him 38 times
already right because you know it's
Serendipity it's Serendip I'm on the
flight I'm in a mood I'm like I I have a
flavor and I'm like yeah let's do it you
right and so relentless pressure on what
you want with tact right you don't want
to come across stalkerish you don't want
to come across you know too tough but
like if You' got value proposition then
you need to tell that story but giving
I'm stunned by the
entitlement of this industry Speck work
don't talk to designers about Speck
workk how evil it is how how is it evil
that you get a chance to prove your work
to somebody and then if it works you
like we have gotten very romantic we've
gotten very soft you know and so I would
say spec Work vom Media I had just built
a $70 million business I was getting
paid $25,000 to speak at that point in
my career I was signed a million dooll
book deal I could have done any
television show I wanted I started a
client service business and didn't work
for people for nothing that's how Vayner
media was
built and then when we killed it for the
NHL and camels and other thing people
were like oh and then I charged
more awesome thank you yeah
ma'am you good on time I don't know
you have a little niece now I know but
I'm waiting for my car we're good cool
more
questions hey gu how's it going I'm
doing really Well's uh Thomas Thomas
pleasure do you go by Thomas like you
like drill that home yes like nobody can
call you Tom you
[Music]
can I don't want to I'm curious in real
life uh professionally Thomas but in
they say like this Tom Tom I don't
really care like with your friends it's
like big daddy T yes all right got all
right um if you find yourself
unfortunately in a market that's really
really oversaturated what are like some
key points that will really make your
personal brand stick out to people who
are booking you or hiring you like I'm
an Entertainer so that's a Biga for me
so here's the hard truth Big Daddy
T number one this is a crazy thing to
say because it's so the truth and it's
such a tough thing to deliver number one
Talent yeah you know like everybody's
like oh it's harder to break through on
YouTube and Twitter now you did it in '
06 I'm like yeah it's harder but people
do every day they're just talented and
you're not right so you know so I would
tell you Talent is a shockingly
intriguing thing but a lot of people
have talent that don't necessarily win
it's about exposure it's about how like
it's about at bats how do you create as
many at bats for you in your story to as
many people that make the decision as
possible and so when I started how do
you get paid $50,000 to speak at a
conference easy I did 23 conferences for
free right I made sure those videos were
on YouTube right I made sure I spoke on
people that blogged about speaking I
emailed speaker dudes.com and I was like
yo you want an interview he's like all
right you know you know and I gave an
interview and four people read that
article right so it's at bats it's
putting yourself in the best position to
succeed to tell your story right and so
you know that can mean a ton of things
so what do you do what do you do you're
a comedian what uh I tour College I was
doing a comedy magic show right so like
you know you really need to think about
there's two ways to play the funnel do
you go after the people that book or do
you get go after the actual consumer and
make them push you up so like one more
time college tours comedian show yes are
you on Vine yeah I'm on Vine how many
Vines have you made cuz I will look it
up and don't lie to me I will call you
out for right [__]
you
got it there's got it there are
comedians right now comedians online are
massively over indexing massively
they're killing it and there's 40 of
them who went from
zero zero in the world to hundreds of
thousands of people following them and
they're getting asked to book every
second got it so you by being here have
enough knowledge about the world that we
live in you need to go all in on it can
I offer bner media complimentary magic
and comy show maybe let me think but
most likely and you know what that's
what it takes right like I'm already a
little more interested you know like
that's what it takes but more than
anything often I'm not lucky enough to
be able to get very practical granular
advice because I'd like to get more
context on what you're actually doing
than doing you know than being wrong if
you do not start making two videos a day
on Vine if you do not leave here tonight
and spend if I me if I I have
spent 300 hours in the last couple of
weeks on Vine trying to learn it then
you should have spent
600 that's what it takes you got
[Music]
it I'm pumped I really think you can
kill mine I hope you're really talented
because if you are and you figure out
how to storytelling six seconds that is
one fertile ground for dudes like you it
is
fertile [__] is fertile
I'm
fertile good
job I do Gary my name is Shai shy
pleasure yeah um I'm actually from close
to where you live I'm from Elizabeth New
Jersey yep not too far away I actually
know I've seen the whole Wine Library
Thing have you been to Bayway
Liquors many the time many time [__]
yeah it's like they know what they're
doing yep uh yeah so um actually my
cooworker and I Johnson Johnson Joseph
and I had had the same question he's out
in the back there he's man uh yeah we we
both uh were curious about I mean from
my perspective I'm coming from a small
town and you know running like a your
dad's company coming into your dad's
company what was the creativity that you
brought to the table as such a young
person coming in like you know it's it's
pretty ballsy to come in and just turn
around a company or to put your efforts
in and make it from a $3 million company
to $30 million company you you got to
remember like you know I think people
gloss over the stories even though they
know them like when you're making $3 to
$4,000 a weekend you know at a mall in
New Jersey selling baseball cards you
know business like I walked in there
like what like I'm about to like I
walked in there with straight bravado
like I know how to sell it was just very
easy for me I just asked com I was there
since I was 14 every weekend and every
summer vacation so I didn't just Walt in
at 22 after partying for four years in
school and like all right what do we do
here like I was in I I worked the floor
of my dad's liquor store for 12 and 14
hours a day for thousands of days before
I ever ran the operations and spoke to
actual customers that actually bought
things and asked them so many questions
could you imagine me at 16 you imagine
walking to a liquor store and seeing the
16-year-old me don't even look at me
because I'm asking you 87 questions to
try to sell you stuff right so I built
up so much knowledge that you know I
walked in there with context too many
people in this room when I mean this
room I mean the world jump into the
businesses that they know nothing about
not of people that start a startup like
yo let's start a music startup because I
listen to music are you an
[__] you're going into the music
business not listening to [__] ASAP
Rocky you dick you know so so I think
that we need to we need to start being
smart about those decisions I think too
many people are jumping in too fast too
many people are starting companies
without knowing the space the hurdles
and the they get caught and they get in
trouble now they get great learnings and
very honestly if you're between 21 and
27 28 I don't know what the right number
is but be risky as hell make a ton of
mistakes it is the time it's perfect
sleep in a little cot of four Dudes do
it like all in like go really raw cuz
the learnings are tremendous on the flip
side you could also go work for some
place that you actually are passionate
about that industry for a year or two
and learn a lot and be in a much better
position to succeed so the naive in the
market is enormous many people think my
story is wild and how I came in and blew
it up so fast I was ready I was a loaded
gun I knew everything about everything
like I went up to Mala College in Boston
I was a [__] student I never went to
class once you know what I was doing I
was driving around Boston going to
Cappies going to Marty's going to all
these like in school like everyone's
like you you going to the party tonight
no I'm going to some random liquor store
2 hours away to walk around for 2 hours
that's who I was I put in the work you
know I don't I know if Malcolm
gladwell's right about 10,000 hours and
all that stuff but I did it I knew
everything I walked in 22 with the
knowledge of a 55-year-old so it was
easy and so I don't think we're putting
in enough work PE read Tech Crunch and
think they know
[Music]
something hey har hey my name's Mike KOA
Mike first of all I am so sorry for the
[Applause]
cursing she's quite used to
it this is uh Mandy koala hey Mandy Hi
how are you isanda Amanda is Mandy is 9
years
old I think of these events there's you
know I think our schooling system has a
lot to change I think you're right and
as a parent and an entrepreneur I own a
couple different businesses and I
constantly am working with her what
advice would you have obviously as a
successful entrepreneur if you could
talk to Mandy right now for two minutes
what would you tell her Mandy don't
listen to a word daddy
[Music]
says listen man I'll be very honest with
you I'm super inspired by you I almost
feel completely inappropriate for me to
tell Mandy anything I think what you're
doing is incredible I have a
four-year-old daughter named Misha that
you know I aspire to have on my lap and
things like this and have these kind of
conversations and raise her in not an
Orthodox way but in a way that I think
will become the future you know I've
always lived in the future right and
that's where a lot of My Success comes
from I I think that Mandy I think that
you may not to answer your question
Mandy I think you may not understand
what I'm about to say but luckily this
is on video and one day you'll watch it
you are very very very lucky to have a
daddy like this and I think that he
really cares and is being thoughtful
about how to create a better life for
you and I think you should kiss him on
the
cheek
[Applause]
hi Mandy by the way please email me at
Gary atger media.com while you're
watching this I know that it's 11 years
from now but I I won't delete that
account just so you email me and I
cannot wait to get your
email Hi Ian bber I met you at your
office during open c i remember and uh
you said something that day that was
profound that everybody said and I think
everybody had a different meaning for it
what does it mean to be native to the
platform I mean it seems like that's a
big yeah like cat phras is becoming like
a cliche has no meaning here's what it
means to me and it was back to the
conversation we had about being cool I
think being native to the platform is so
Brands and and businesses and Business
Schools and higher education and all
that stuff likes to create these
scenarios of know your voice right know
your voice and then pound it I think
which I believe in know your story but I
know when to wear this gear and talk
like I'm talking because I know my
audience right I know that you know you
know that I go to different conferences
and I know the things I can and can't
say I know when I'm on television I
don't curse it's not going to work for
me you it's not going to work out well
when I go out to dinner with my parents
I'm a different version of who I am when
I go out to Vegas with my boys for the
weekend I'm a different version of who I
am and I think we all need to start
respecting the context of the
environment and so what that means being
native to the platform is if you're a
business if you're an Entertainer and
you're jumping on Tumblr you better know
a couple of things you better know how
to be pretty damn cool cuz Tumblr is
pretty cool it's Young You Better Know
That animated gifts is how you tell the
story not GIF son you know and so I
think you know you need to know that if
you go to Pinterest you're speaking to a
female demo and you need to come across
with your copy and your pictures in that
way you need to know that when you're on
Vine you're making videos for 8 to 18y
olds right now they'll get older and you
need to make them laugh not a 38-year
old so I'm going to make wine videos on
Vine but it's not going to catch on I'm
doing it because in four years when
everybody's on there I'll be there got
it so you have to know the flavor of the
room how to dress how to talk what's
appropriate for that setting when you
story tell cuz it's very different on
Facebook Twitter Tumblr Pinterest
Instagram Snapchat very
different got it so telling the same
story in nine different ways because
those platforms demand it and more
importantly the psychology of everybody
here when they're on those platforms is
different depending on the platform
something we don't spend enough time
talking
about hey uh Gary it's Dave I also me
met you at your office I don't know if
you remember the
trophy of um they're amazing trophies
thank you thank you um my question is I
know you talk so much about uh uh you
know never just always pushing and and
uh doing as much as you can what about
uh now that you're a dad how do you turn
it off when you get home easily my my
family is everything to me right by the
way the only reason I always talk about
pushing
and like you know this whole workp life
balance thing is I know everybody you
know you're listening to me for 2
minutes and 37 seconds on YouTube the
rest of the time you're pushing very
often in the other direction we're all
worried about life work life balance
it's the by the way it's the only thing
I care about this was tough for me today
this was this moment has been very tough
for me I'm sitting through a tough
moment right now now now that this is
the fourth child between my sister and I
I know that you don't have to be there
right that second to still have it but
if this was our first like I wouldn't be
here I would have canceled like I've
learned a but like you know like you're
always battling you're always making
decisions do I let we work down and all
the people that wanted to be here
tonight is that the right value exchange
for being there an hour or two earlier
like you're going through these every
day like I'm struggling with it every
day but I'm also not struggling with it
which is meaning we're all doing the
best we can right and nobody can tell
you that like for everybody's like oh I
spend more time with my family I'm like
yeah but that guy spends more time than
you so who won did wi like like we're
all different we all listen my wife
Lizzie is amazingly independent she's
just amazingly independent woman who
like is very similar to me and like in
her stuff and like loves her stuff like
she doesn't need me there every second
she probably doesn't want me there every
second you know and so right and so like
but it's a balance but I will tell you
this there is one answer there's one
real answer
communication heavy over the toop Allin
communication I check in with with her
we talk about stuff I check in with the
rest of my family members and friends
you just have to talk a lot and like cuz
you're feeling things what are they
feeling I you know for a spouse you know
heavy communication for your children
when they're younger it's hard you can't
have that talk necessarily but I'm super
aware of the lack of time I spent with
my dad growing up I didn't know him
until I was 14 I know what it felt like
to be the only kid in my league to not
have his dad come to his little league
games I know what feels like so um and
it was fine by the way you know like
that's just who I was I was cool with
that I was like dad's trying to make it
like even at that age right and mom was
enough and like it was fine I was scared
of my dad anyway and so you know I I
just think it's communication my man
it's a very touchy subject I talk a lot
about hustle and Allin I always get
worried that people you know luckily I
think people have a sense of where I sit
on family but like you know I
mean and it evolves I'm taking every day
except for six off in August this year
to go up to a house in Connecticut and
spend time with my family that's more
days off than I took for 11 years in a
row combined right so you evolved and
different things happen what I don't
want to tell you and Nate's laughing is
I'm probably going to be emailing every
want of you individually in that month
asking you to buy my book you know and
so like I'm going to hustle as well but
I'll be hustling with them around and so
you got to you got to evolve there's an
evolution to
this can you stay in touch with AJ on on
the car thanks man hey man what's up how
you doing I'm James um you once told me
uh never take the first dollar when
there's a $20 bill waiting down the road
yeah um is that what Jay-Z just did by
giving up the Nets and going into the
sports arena well he took both dollars
so how does that apply like can you
expand on not chasing that first dollar
and going after I mean I think it I
think I think you know it's all the
context right jam and I don't very
honestly I apologize I don't completely
remember the context of where that
answer came through it it comes into a
lot of different plays my man it comes
down like
this your time is your asset you know
Vayner media we're a premium agency we
get hundreds of emails of people that
want to work with us but can't afford us
cuz we've gotten expensive because we've
got enough demand for the supply now if
you don't have a lot of demand or don't
think there'll be a lot of demand take
that first dollar but I think a lot of
times people jump at that first dollar
when there's where you could build a
little bit more just a little more
there's plenty of people that have sold
their all the you know how we celebrate
companies that have exited you know we
read Tech runch or out yeah they've sold
sometimes like boo I'm like one more
year two more years YouTube wishes they
waited understand and a lot of people do
there's a lot of people now plenty of
people wish they took so you have to be
self-aware but I you know but I think if
it's predicated on your time you need to
be very smart about it because every
time you take something you just said no
to something
else I have one question sure so two
parts Mark Sanchez or Gino Smith and
what's the state of New York Jacks in
2013 great so I think from The Mark
Sanchez goo smith thing I think that
thing plays itself out right like
whoever whoever wins this preseason I'm
fine with you know capitalism I think
every quarterback competition should be
capitalism it's the most important spot
it's the CEO job um the state of this
year's team we'll see I think that
unfortunately their schedule is a little
harder than I'd like it to be um I think
that they'll probably be a little bit
better than people think because their
defense is going to be really strong but
um I'm
concerned anybody else there's got to be
other
questions don't be scared
hiis I'm taking pictures thank you so
much left
side um you were talking about all these
platforms but beond Vine uh probably not
Snapchat um is there anything where you
actually feel that you're too old for um
for example I mean I can't be on Vine
just T you can't be on Vine consuming
the videos because they seem too young
for you it's just yeah it's like having
ad for me yeah I get it
um no because I don't actually think of
myself as a customer of any of these
platforms I don't use any of these
Platforms in a real way this is my
career and my job and just like it took
me 2 and a half years to unwind from
being in the wine business every day to
now it's guys it's so weird I actually
go out now and like drink wine like a
normal person like I enjoy it like I
used to five minutes I used to drink
wine like for my whole life and think it
was like a chore I drink it i' be like
oh how they do that like what how much
does this cost should I buy this and
sell you know should I review this on
the show it was like a job and that's
how social is for me I don't use
Snapchat like most people use Snapchat I
use it trying to figure out what the
business uses are so I don't consume
Vine for my entertainment I consume it
as somebody who's trying to figure out
the architecture and opportunities
around it so I never feel old as a
matter of fact I spend most of my time
trying to spend time on the young stuff
because I never want to be the guy that
I make fun of I want to be very in tune
I'm I've got an office full of 200
employees that are 27 and under and I'm
the youngest guy in the building for my
usage I just
am I'm also the
busiest just want you guys to know that
I'm younger and busier and hustling more
than you guys so step up I'm just
kidding kidding not
really by way thank you so much brother
um by the way I'm really into what
you're doing with your hair and please
please keep it going like I need to see
you like another 24 months from now you
got it thank you um so you put out a
piece of content I think it was a video
where you mentioned that people should
treat their businesses like their second
child rather than their first child yes
and so obviously when you have your
first child you don't have that
mentality so um from a business
perspective where can you draw the line
to say okay now you can start treating
your business as a second child cuz you
have those things that you've learned
that you can now apply there so where do
you draw the line I tried to use that
analogy to make I could have said this I
like analogies you know me right so
that's why I made that video was fun I
was thinking about this I was coming out
of a meeting where I was proud of myself
which happens often with the way I feel
about myself but something happened
where it really worked out for Vayner
and I was just so happy again because
everything on paper said that we should
have worried about X Y and Z and I
didn't and it really worked it just
reminded me again like God damn it
people are spending too much time
worrying about the things that don't
matter 1% of the things that are
happening in your business matter one
one and like like now I don't know how
to like teach I'm not good at teaching
what that 1% if I worked if I join your
business I'd tell you in two minutes
right 6 weeks in I'd have it it's why
vayer Works cuz I think I'm good for the
business bus we work in forget the
social I think I know how to run their
businesses better um so that's what that
meant what I've learned after having a
second child is we're not micromanaging
every little thing that we did with the
first child I mean Xander's walking I
mean Xander's like on the street we're
like cool you good ex good you know like
Misha couldn't like go one step like I
mean you know we like she would sleep
and we'd look at her face for an hour
right so um I mean I went into Misha's
room 700 times in the first couple years
like just making sure she was breathing
right like you just get scared it's just
like intense love with business I was
mature already with my library back to
the baseball card stuff I knew and I'm
just trying to help young entrepreneurs
to just like take a step back and
realize like okay like I'm always
telling my team like okay end good
they'll fire us we're still rolling we
have plenty of new business I care more
about your feelings don't get too
pressure like so I just I'm just trying
to figure out you know I'm always taking
stabs at trying to tell a story in a
certain way
that might hit home that one was
actually directed towards a little bit
of an older crowd cuz they have had two
children and they know exactly what I'm
talking about cuz the first child you
know like was perfect the second one's
like eating dirt outside while you're
inside right and so that's you know
obviously when you're going through it
your first time you don't have that
context of what that is but you're
gaining context right away when you're
into your business you can look back at
all the things you worried about that
weren't that serious try to imply the
past into future future
[Music]
decisions I think we're going to give
the mic back to Jesse he'll ask a couple
more questions and we'll wrap up yeah
and I know that we were supposed to do a
video can I come back and do it another
time cool cuz if you said no I would
have made you feel so
guilty will come to you what's that come
to you yeah come to me we want to shoot
some filter
out um so I know you're on your way I
had one question you brought up probably
a 100 times this conversation
storytelling
something that you are a master at who
maybe how many think about how many
people here know lemonade and baseball
cards and like things that people know
in like ingrained in their mind um it's
super important so so the question and
and I think it could benefit the whole
audience is and especially me is uh how
do you what is your perfect story what
is the best story to you how do you tell
it what what are the ingredients that go
into it that really get your point
across and and that's a good question I
think the first one starts with the
truth you know too many people telling
stories that aren't real so I think the
truth really matters because people's
[__] Radars are much better than we
give them credit for so I think that
matters I think that you know I don't
really know how to answer this question
right I've always been good at it's the
same reason I'm a good salesman it's the
same reason I think I'm a good angel
investor I just always think about the
other person and so if I can give you a
tactical thing if you can I think
scratching your own itch is a very good
place to go so I curse a lot and act
like I do on stage because I loved
growing up watching Richard prior and
Eddie Murphy I watched a lot of them all
the time 247 when I got my car I didn't
listen to music I listen to them on my
tape cassette I'm old all that stuff
right and so you know you can see it in
my style I'm scratching my own itch I'm
giving business business Keynotes the
way I think they would almost in essence
do a standup routine even my rhythm
delivers in a joke a lot of times and a
punchline so that's what I was inspired
by I would tell you think about how you
would want a story told to you and tell
it that way reverse engineer what feels
good to you cuz a lot of people look
like you I my fan base are versions of
me Academia is not rolling up in here
saying yeah except brilliant Academia
people you know so you know you know who
rolls you know who likes me people like
me because I'm storytelling to me I want
the truth I want the raw truth I I feel
so bad to people that pitch me like they
get I'm sure like especially when it
matters because they're trying to get
money or get me my business they take a
lot of time and they practice and they
think about it and they walk in they're
like all right here I'm like good next
like I'm out in like 4 seconds cuz I got
it like I don't want you to waste my
time like yes okay you're a mobile
company I get it yes I understand
There's an opportunity like get to the
hook right and
so yeah scratch your own itch tell the
story the way that you would want it
told to you I think is a very good
fundamental way to think about it cool
thank you guys so
much yeah